Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
As you know, I absolutely loved Zootopia,
and each time I watch the movie, I find something
new to enjoy.
But because of the way animated movies are
made, there's often tons of incredible stuff
that the animators work on which doesn't make
it into the final movie.
So, in this video, I'm going to be taking
a look at the dozens of amazing deleted scenes
and rejected ideas from Zootopia that hit
the cutting room floor.
And a quick warning that of course there are
spoilers ahead, so if you want to avoid any
spoilers, click here for my spoiler-free review
or come back after you've seen the movie.
Just before I get started I've got another
fantastic copy of this gorgeous hardback book
The Art of Zootropolis to give away.
All you have to do is subscribe and leave
a comment about the deleted scenes on this
video.
To give you an idea of what you can look forward
to in the book, there's tons of amazing concept
art, sketches, and information that give an
incredible peek into the making of the movie.
First up is the movie's opening scene which
sets Judy up to become a police officer in
Zootopia although in a different way than
we see in the final movie.
The alternate opening is set in Woodlands
Elementary School rather than at the Carrot
Days Festival and has Judy practising a song
with her classmates while their teacher Mrs
Armadillo accompanies them on the piano.
Judy's friends each sing a line about what
they want to be when they grow up, but when
it comes to Judy's turn, she won't sing that
she wants to grow carrots.
This opening establishes how animals are stereotyped,
for example, Sally the squirrel sings that
she wants to sell nuts and the Rory the racoon
sings that he wants to drive a trash truck.
But Judy proves she's capable of other things
when Bobby Catmull the cougar cub is about
to fall out of a tree.
Judy grabs Mrs Armadillo's laser pen and gets
Bobby to chase its light down the tree to
safety.
A police offer then arrives and gives Judy
a Junior ZPD badge and says she should become
a police officer.
And when Judy's classmate scoffs that she's
just a bunny, the officer replies "This is
Zootopia where anyone can be anything", a
moment which echoes what Judy does and says
to Finnick later in the final movie.
Other elements from this alternate opening
scene also appeared in a slightly different
form in the final movie.
Bobby Catmull appears as the cougar who creates
the various sound effects during Judy's performance
at Carrot Days and Mrs Armadillo is the landlady
at Judy's apartment complex.
And the scene in the alternate opening which
features a deer being mock-attacked by a predator
as part of the rehearsals for the school's
show mirrors both the dramatic scene Judy
performs with fake blood in the opening of
the final movie and also the final movie's
climactic showdown when Nick fakes turning
savage to catch Bellwether.
Since Zootopia came out, there've been tons
of fans shipping Judy and Nick, and an incredible
amount of fan art on just that subject.
So, shippers of Nick and Judy everywhere will
likely love this next deleted scene I'm going
to talk about which features Nick meeting
Judy's parents and her dad assuming that Nick
is Judy's boyfriend!
The scene would have appeared in the movie
just after everyone's favourite fox and bunny
team escape Manchas who's gone savage.
In the scene, Judy and Nick arrive at her
very pink apartment which prompts Nick to
question Judy's description of where they
were going as a 'safe-house'.
Judy's reply that it's a 'safe house, with
a space in the middle, a house that is safe'
is a fantastic riff on Nick's earlier words
to Judy that he was not falsely advertising
the Redwood he sold the rodents as it was
actually 'red wood with a space in the middle,
wood that is red'.
Judy's family have come to the big city to
pay her a surprise visit, and when Judy's
father first sees Nick, he asks her to pass
him the fox-taser, and then worries that Nick
is her boyfriend.
The family also discovers that Judy is a meter
maid, not a real cop as she'd led them to
believe, so her father demands that she leave
Zootopia and return home with them, but Nick
steps in to defend her.
In the final movie, this moment was replaced
with Chief Bogo rather than her father trying
to make Judy leave the police force.
There are some really amazing designs for
Judy's family home in Bunnyburrow that didn't
make it to the final movie.
The huge size of Judy's family and house was
going to be a major feature of the film with
over 200 bunnies running around.
In fact, originally, Judy's family was so
large that her father couldn't even remember
her name!
Also, the family home was going to be centred
around a constantly-in-use kitchen and a dining
area that rotated slowly allowing new hungry
bunnies to take the place of bunnies who'd
already finished eating.
And The Bunnyburrow district was also going
to feature more of the Totoro-inspired buildings
we only saw briefly in the final film at the
Bunnyburrow train station.
During the chase through Little Rodentia,
you might have spotted a billboard for the
fast food restaurant Chez Cheese.
In an early draft of the movie, Finnick would
take the drive-thru orders making use of his
giant ears while Nick worked cleaning the
cheese filters.
In that version of the movie, Clawhauser was
also a delivery cheetah for the restaurant,
making deliveries to the district's rodents.
Chez Cheese was going to tell the story of
how Nick and Finnick met.
The movie's co-director Jared Bush has said
this was his favourite deleted location and
that he'd love to see a short film featuring
the fast food joint.
Another fast food joint which didn't appear
was Bug-Burga which is where Zootopia's predators
would go to eat.
Because predators don't eat other animals
in Zootopia, to get their protein they eat
insects, so Bug-Burga served up "grasshopper
shakes, cricket chips and cicada burgers."
There is a tiny reference to Bug-Burga in
the final film in the scene where Nick is
leading Judy through an alleyway shortcut
and there are some Bug-Burga fast food boxes
littered on the ground.
Originally, there was going to be more of
Nick's backstory explored in the film, including
a scene where we get to see Nick as a cub
with his father.
It's a touching moment where Nick's father
goes with his son to pitch a business idea
for a loan so he can start his own family
tailoring shop called Suit-topia.
The scene wasn't used as it was part of the
initial idea for the film where the story
was told from Nick's perspective as the central
character, rather than through Judy's eyes.
We know Nick has always had an entrepreneurial
mind with his pawpsicle business, but in an
early version of Zootopia, just like his father,
Nick went to the Zootopian banks to pitch
a business idea, but Nick's idea was for an
entertainment venue called Wild Times.
In a scene which was actually voiced by Jason
Bateman, Nick explained his idea to all of
the city's bankers, who just happened to all
be prey.
It's a funny scene where Nick visits banks
like Lemming Brothers, Borrow Burrow, JP Mare-Gan
and Slothoman Brothers, and gets rejected
every time.
Eventually, Nick ends up visiting the polar
bear gangster boss Koslov who loans him the
money.
The designs for Wild Times were well-advanced
before the idea was abandoned.
Wild Times was an indoor arcade where predators
could let their instincts loose a little.
The amusement park featured a huge range of
games and rides.
For example, there was a roller coaster called
the Roar-A-Coaster where predators could roar
and be themselves.
By the way, there's a glimpse of what might
have been the building for Wild Times in the
scene where Judy goes to find Nick by the
small stone bridge.
Koslov, who Nick takes a loan from to finance
his Wild Times arcade, did appear in the final
movie as the polar bear who carries Mr Big
in his hands when Nick and Judy have been
caught by Kevin and Raymond.
In earlier versions though, he ran the mafia
in Tundra Town and he owned a restaurant called
Koslov's Palace which served as a front for
his shady operations.
The design of the interior of Koslov's Palace
used warm colours to contrast with the icy
blue and white of the cold exterior.
The scene we see in the final movie of Nick
and Finnick hustling Judy into paying for
their Jumbo Pop is a much revised version
from an earlier version of the movie.
That early alternate scene in Jumbeaux's Café
shows Nick claiming that his son has a condition
called "pachydermiopathy", which according
to Nick means that his son thinks he's an
elephant.
Nick and Finnick put on a hilarious performance
with Nick begging the ice cream parlour owner
not to break his son's heart when he refuses
to serve him what he wants, and then to cap
it all Nick claims he left his wallet at the
orphanage.
Nick senses Judy's fallen for his scheme,
so lays the sob story on even further, which
ends in Judy pulling out her cash to pay.
It's still very funny as it displays Nick
and Finnick's con-man skills although Judy
probably comes off a bit more naïve and silly
in this version.
In the final movie, after Judy discovers she
was hustled by Nick, she goes back to her
apartment feeling really fed up, and gets
a call from her parents who discover she's
just a meter maid.
There's an earlier and longer version of this
scene where we see Judy travel back to the
apartment on the subway, getting squashed
by two larger animals.
In this version, after discarding her microwaved
carrots for one, she goes to call her mum,
but stops herself.
However, the phone accidentally dials and
she ends up talking to her parents and her
grandfather who's very prejudiced against
foxes.
In this version, her parents don't realise
she's just a meter maid which makes Judy feel
guilty for hiding the truth from them.
It's a much sadder version of the scene than
the one in the movie and ends with Judy curling
up on her bed among her cuddly toys.
By the way, Judy's grandfather "Pop-Pop" is
the rabbit we see at the train station in
the final movie, the one who bears a very
close resemblance to Carl from Up.
There's a deleted scene in which Judy starts
her investigation into the missing otter,
Emmet Otterton, by using the office and computer
of an elephant cop who's away on vacation.
It's a fun scene where Judy has to use her
agility to use a computer that's way bigger
than she is.
The scene was edited out of the final movie
to keep the film's pace up and to show Judy
getting her lead on Otterton by working more
closely with Clawhauser.
Designs for a rough biker-style bar for sheep
were developed although the location didn't
make it into the final film.
The bar was called The Cloven Hoof and it
was set in a sleazy part of town.
It's likely that we would have seen Doug and
other bad sheep like Jesse and Woolter hanging
out here.
The filmmakers also had plans for a Nocturnal
District, which was going to be an area of
caves underneath the city where nocturnal
animals like bats would live.
In the end, Zootopia's story didn't require
the location so the idea wasn't fully developed,
however, it might be linked to the Bat Eyewitness
figure who appears together with Clawhauser
in Zootopia character packs, and who is described
as visiting Clawhauser at the police station
quite frequently as he often witnesses crimes.
The Meadowlands is another district that we
never got to see properly.
It's basically a broad grassland area where
the sheep and grazing animals live.
We did get a tiny peek at the edge of the
Meadowlands though, as the Cliffside Asylum
was just on the border.
In an early draft of the movie, there was
a sheep conspiracy where sheep would disguise
themselves as wolves to deliberately incriminate
predators, making them look dangerous.
If you'd like to find out about one of the
sheep characters, called Wooly, who used to
do this, then check out my video on Zootopia's
Deleted Characters.
Another location that didn't make it into
the final film was Outback Island, which was
home to Australian animals such as kangaroos,
koalas, platypuses and dingos, who all together
were known as "Outbackers".
This location was cut as it didn't fit the
main story, although it does appear in the
book "Zootopia: The Stinky Cheese Caper (and
Other Cases from the ZPD Files)."
There was an additional scene at the Natural
History Museum which was cut from the film
due to time constraints.
The cut scene featured Bellwether making a
speech to Judy about the origins of Zootopia.
Those origins relate back to a painting which
if you're extremely eagle-eyed you can glimpse
in the museum as well as at the subway station.
The painting shows lions and zebras shaking
paws and agreeing to predators and prey living
in peace.
While giving the speech in this scene, Bellwether
looks out at and talks about the fountain
in the square which represents the watering
hole around which the animals bonded when
they declared peace.
Although we do get to see the Palm Hotel and
Casino on the train ride Judy takes into the
city when she arrives, there were also extensive
designs and scenes storyboarded inside the
hotel that did not get used.
The design of the hotel was inspired by super-luxurious
hotels in Dubai, and Gazelle had a penthouse
apartment at the Palm hotel.
A scene with Judy and Nick falling down the
side of the hotel while escaping from a ram
was storyboarded but dropped in favour of
the scene in the Rainforest District where
Judy and Nick fall through the vines while
escaping from the savage Manchas.
An earlier version of the movie's action-packed
finale was set in a large stadium called Zootennial
Stadium.
There was going to be a spectacular Olympic
Games-style opening show called Animalia which
showcased the history of Zootopia.
It was going to feature Gazelle, who's a prey
animal, performing with her predator back-up
dancers.
And there were going to be flying squirrels
and pigs, and animals shot out of confetti
cannons.
And that huge show would have acted as the
backdrop for the movie's climactic showdown.
The film did, of course, end with Gazelle
performing with her tiger dancers at a pop
concert, but that was after Judy and Nick
had already caught the baddies.
The final version we see in the movie was
a cool way to show off the movie's credits.
So guys, do you think any of those deleted
scenes or ideas should have been in the final
movie?
And what would you like to see in a Zootopia
sequel?
I can't wait to hear your thoughts in the
comments below.
And don't forget to subscribe and comment
for your chance to win this beautiful Art
of Zootropolis hardback book.
If you enjoyed this video, check out my other
Zootopia videos including 7 awesome characters
who were deleted from the movie, 25 things
you didn't know about the making of Zootopia,
and also coming shortly I'll have a brand
new easter egg video.
You'll be able to find all them right here
in my full Zootopia video playlist.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!